I got this bag from the TikTok shop,
and I just got back from the grocery store.
And I want to show you how much shit is in this bag. Look,
this is my heavy shit bag.
Look.
Glass bottle. Kombucha.
Tastes like shit,
but it's good for your gut.
Salad dressing,
hard, heavy shit.
More heavy shit.
These fucking teas are delicious,
but this is all heavy shit.
Heavy,
heavy.
Check this shit out.
Boom! And a gallon of milk in this fucking bag.
In Colorado, we.
Plastic bags are illegal.
They don't even sell them at the fucking grocery store.
You need something like this.
And this shit is.
I initially was like,
I wanna go to the beach.
My ass is in Colorado.
I'm not going to the beach.
This shit perfect for the grocery store.